sécheresse mauvaises récoltes canicule
de plus en plus de terres fertiles
laisse place au désert
le permafrost se transforme peu à peu en
marécages et glaciers fondent le climat
de la terre est aujourd'hui plus chaud
qu'il ne l'a été au cours des cent mille
dernières années à la fin du siècle
il fera encore plus chaud un degré plus
bien sûr que non si la température
moyenne augmente de 1,5 3 ou 5 degrés
cela entraînera d'importants
bouleversements à quel impact faut-il
s'attendre
seront ils visible dans l'environnement
l'économie et la politique
personne ne le sait pour l'instant
[Musique]
adil ahmad abdallah vie dans le
gouvernorat de taïso au yémen je suis
agriculteur on travaille permet de
nourrir ma famille
douze personnes nous aimons tous
l'agriculture même si nous devons
travailler la terre matin midi et soir
nous aimons notre mode de vie et notre
travail
[Musique]
il est temps de semer le blé a dit il
paie son voisin qui a encore du bétail
pour qu'il fasse ce travail
[Musique]
nous avions aussi des vaches et du
fourrage pour tous types de bétail
maintenant tout a changé pas nous devons
travailler la terre différemment climat
le changement climatique peut être
observée partout sur la planète
le yémen est l'un des pays où les
températures ont augmenté les
agriculteurs en ont été les premières
victimes
comment ça va tout va bien là soit loué
en fait rien ne va réellement bien mais
les habitants font du mieux qu'ils
peuvent
le climat a changé il ya de moins en
moins de précipitation la saison des
semailles commence donc un peu plus tard
chaque année comment pouvons-nous
travailler cette terre tous les puits
sont à sec
il y avait beaucoup de bétail avant
aujourd'hui il est impossible d'avoir
des animaux
rien ne pousse ici comment gérer les
animaux on a dû vendre le bétail j'ai
vendu le mien comme beaucoup d'autres
fermiers
[Musique]
il y a un peu d'eau dans un grand
réservoir rouge dans la cour d'un deal
mais elle doit être utilisé avec
parcimonie
lol les pouces d'adil en a marre d'en
parler
nous n'avons rien pas de vêtements pas
d'essence pas d'autres connaissent rien
du tout oui nous n'avons rien la terre
est mauvaise mauvaise pas de pluie il
n'y a rien ici à doha bois pas d'eau
pour la maison pas d'eau pour se laver
il n'y a rien ici il n'y a pas d'eau on
doit partir d'ici
le plus vite possible sinon ne survivra
pas nous sommes tous pour dans cette
région tout le monde est pauvre nous
n'avons absolument rien rien du tout 1
souffre d'une terrible pénurie d'eau
comment peut-on travailler la terre sans
eau
c'est notre seul gagne autant notre pays
considéré comme l'un des plus touchés
par la sécheresse et la désertification
dans le monde comme le montre la
recherche stratégique sur les ressources
en eau renouvelable au yémen il y a
environ 125 mètres cubes d'eau par
habitant
cela signifie que pour ce qui est des
ressources en eau souterraine
renouvelables et yémen est le pays le
plus pauvre du monde
[Musique]
le ministère de l'agriculture fwa date
el jalil travail comme agronome n'est
pas en mesure d'aider les agriculteurs
l'économie et méditer trop faible en
l'inflation atteint 40% les prix des
produits essentiels comme industrielles
ont augmenté
ils sont très élevés pour vous donner un
exemple 25 kg d'engrais ne coûtait
presque rien maintenant ils sont vendus
65000 rial le sac 65000 rials soit 260
dollars américains environ une dépense
que le co ne peuvent se permettre
[Musique]
ici sur le bord de la route les gens
essayent de vendre toutes sortes de
bibelots de légumes et de vêtements pour
gagner au moins un peu d'argent
[Musique]
heureusement l'aube ce puits y est
gratuite la station de pompage est
financé par un homme aisé originaire de
ce village mais qui a déménagé il y a
longtemps on couvre les bouteilles de
plastique pour ne rien renversé et les
enfants les remporte à la maison ces
taux ne sera pas utilisée pour
l'irrigation
tout a changé il fait plus chaud c'est
tout à fait différent maintenant il ne
pleut jamais alors les gens désespèrent
n'avons ni pluie ni travail
dieu sait que les gens parc les gens
tout cet endroit regardez nous n'avons
absolument rien et c'est une leçon de
géographie à l'école le sujet
d'aujourd'hui et le réchauffement
climatique ce qui concerne
particulièrement les yéménites
l'un des problèmes environnementaux
majeurs et le changement climatique
il ya pour conséquence une hausse des
températures dans le monde entier
elle a un impact négatif sur la vie de
toute l'humanité et sur celle de la
population yéménite en particulier outre
le changement climatique il faut faire
face à la pollution de l'environnement
et de l'eau c'est une affiche de la
youth initiative organisation qui a été
fondée par les gens de la région
il travaille à la prévention de l'eau et
à la protection des conditions
favorables à l'agriculture
je veux que la guerre prenne fin on a
quitté nos foyers et déménagé ici pour
être en sécurité mais on se fait tuer
ici aussi la guerre a détruit
l'agriculture la vie des paysans tout ce
dont je rêve c'est de vivre en paix et
de mettre fin à cette guerre qui se
poursuit
je veux vivre et faire mes études dans
un endroit sûr loin du front j'espère
que ce sera bientôt le cas dans le
sillage des troubles de 2011 en afrique
du nord et au moyen-orient
connu sous le nom de printemps arabe un
nouveau président est arrivé au pouvoir
au yémen
un conflit armé qui a éclaté en 2015
selon l'onu fin 2018
la moitié de la population yéménite 16
millions de personnes étaient menacées
de famine
habituellement l'instabilité politique
et les guerres ils sont considérés comme
les causes de telles crises humanitaires
jesús crespo ou quaresma est l'un des
auteurs de la première étude visant à
prouver que les changements climatiques
peuvent être l'un des facteurs à
l'origine des crises humanitaires
migration de masse et guerres récentes
[Musique]
on a beaucoup écrit sur la façon dont la
sécheresse et les mauvaises récoltes
sont à l'origine des migrations internes
des zones rurales vers les villes
ces phénomènes exacerbe en outre
généralement les conflits internes
l'attend apparu avant même la sécheresse
[Musique]
les chercheurs ont étudié des données
portant sur une période de dix ans de
2006 à 2015 sur l'origine de la plupart
des réfugiés et les conditions
météorologiques dans ces régions
on une corrélation peut voir que cela
remonte à 2010 quand c'est à dire que le
conflit en syrie le printemps arabe et
certains conflits en afrique
subsaharienne ont été causés dans une
certaine mesure par les conditions
climatiques particules à l'imf lohan
spike la marque en défense le
réchauffement de la planète
les conflits militaires les changements
climatiques et la tragédie que vivent
des millions de réfugiés
le lien entre environnement et politique
est une nouvelle réalité et même plus
que ça c'est l'avenir de la planète
ali mahdjoub hassan est la preuve
vivante de la théorie des chercheurs
viennois il est l'un des nombreux
paysans yéménites qui ont dû déménager
en ville pour trouver un emploi
je travaillais la terre autrefois pour
être honnête je vivais bien je vivais de
la terre les récoltes étaient bonnes
surtout quand il pleuvait la terre était
fertile est les récoltes abondantes les
puits était plein d'eau ali mahdjoub
hassan est rentré à son domicile pour
retrouver sa femme et ses cinq enfants
pour quelques jours et participer aux
tâches ménagères
il revient dans son village natal tous
les six mois par ont vite pour gagner
notre vie afin que nos familles puissent
se permettre au moins quelque chose
les choses les plus simples mon salaire
n'est pas suffisant pour subvenir aux
besoins de ma famille et la guerre est
toujours en cours tout devient de plus
en plus cher dieu seul sait ce qu'il
adviendra de nous
le gouvernorat de taïz est la région la
plus touchée par la guerre au yémen
une organisation caritative fourni
gratuitement des produits alimentaires
des soins médicaux et de loups à la
population de taiz à cause des nombreux
problèmes économiques il est devenu plus
difficile d'acheter de l'eau ces jours
ci le prix de l'eau a augmenté d'abord
de 50 % puis de 100% et aujourd'hui son
prix a encore doublé voire plus des
philanthropes prévoit de construire une
station de pompage d'eau potable dans
une région où sévit un tel climat
c'est une question de vie ou de mort
beaucoup de gens dans les zones rurales
comme dans les villes ne peuvent se
permettre d'acheter de l'eau il souffre
d'un manque de ressources et boivent de
l'eau sale ils prennent des puits et des
eaux stagnantes
c'est pour ça que le choléra et d'autres
maladies infectieuses se propage à taïz
la capitale du gouvernorat la ville de
taiz avec sa population de plus de six
cent mille habitants est l'une des plus
grandes villes du pays
il
c'est ici qu'elle y met djouba ça n'a
déménagé à deux heures de voiture de son
village
mais ali n'a pas de voiture il gagne sa
vie en revendant des confiseries un
carrefour
je veux quitter cet endroit je
déménagerai vers n'importe quelle autre
région au pays où il est plus facile de
trouver un emploi afin d'avoir un
travail qui me rapporterai assez
d'argent
les températures ne retomberont pas au
yémen ali mahdjoub hassan ne retournera
pas à ses champs il travaillera à temps
partiel en ville et sa famille finira
par les rejoindre la détérioration du
climat au yémen l'effondrement des
structures sociales traditionnelles le
réchauffement climatique et les vagues
de réfugiés de nouveau des airs vers
d'autres pays
tout cela est inévitable en fait au lieu
de parler de réchauffement serait plus
correct de parler de changements
climatiques globaux
parce que les gens peuvent influer sur
le climat non seulement par les
émissions de co2 mais aussi par exemple
par la déforestation
couper les arbres et au lieu des forêts
c'est que vous obtenez est un désert
lorsqu'un désert secret la situation
change
ce n'est donc pas seulement que le
climat change par lui-même à cause de
certains facteurs externes naturel nous
créons les conditions favorables un
changement climatique l'incommensurable
impacts des activités humaines sur le
climat sur toute la planète a donné
naissance à l'hypothèse dit de
l'anthropocène
c'est à dire l'air géologique à laquelle
l'homme a commencé à influencer
directement la planète
le géologue mais quelle vague reich est
l'un des défenseurs de cette théorie
[Musique]
bien sûr les gens créent des sources
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre de
dioxyde de carbone qui vous mènera les
gens influe sur beaucoup de processus
itératif tels que le cycle du carbone
insight de la zone je constate qu'il y a
beaucoup de preuves laissant penser
qu'il ya des changements
[Musique]
tromsoe norvège à environ 6000
kilomètres du yémen mais en norvège
aussi on peut constater un changement
climatique à peu près similaire
[Applaudissements]
des étudiants faisant partie de la
nature and youth organization se prépare
pour la grève pour le climat qui aura
lieu vendredi
tous les norvégiens sont conscients
qu'il est nécessaire de réduire les
émissions de substances nocives
mais les actes des adultes à cet égard
sont considérés comme trop timides par
les adolescentes
nous sommes pour la réduction des
émissions de substances dangereuses dans
l'atmosphère on propose de réduire les
émissions de 11 % voire de 50% ou soyons
plus audacieux et exigeons une réduction
des émissions de 50 % dès le départ en
tout cas ça doit être certainement plus
de 11% 11% n'est peut-être pas suffisant
[Applaudissements]
l'homme de l'anthropocène demande des
mesures drastiques
changeons le système pas le climat
changeant le système pas le climat
les grèves scolaire du vendredi a
commencé en 2018 en suède
à l'initiative de la désormais célèbre
écolière de stockholm et à thoune l'erc
aujourd'hui le monde entier est familier
avec ce moyen d'attirer l'attention sur
cette situation désastreuse
mais résoudre ce problème est plus
difficile qu'il n'y paraît
[Musique]
à deux paroles des actes
malheureusement les gens ne pensent pas
beaucoup aux problèmes climatiques par
exemple les hommes politiques de droite
qui sont riches ne veulent pas qu'ils
aient de migrants dans notre pays et
préconise le durcissement des politiques
migratoires mais il ne pense pas du tout
changement climatique
ils ne comprennent pas que les
migrations environnementales ne feront
que s'accroître à l'avenir les gens
quittent leur pays pas seulement à cause
des guerres mais aussi parce qu'il
devient impossible de vivre en afrique
et ailleurs
s'il n'y avait pas de raison à cela les
migrants ne viendrait pas ici
la feuille de route des militants pour
le climat signé en 2016
l'accord de paris sur le changement
climatique n'est pas obligatoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les signataires ont reconnu
l'augmentation inévitable des
température moyenne à la surface de la
terre
cela ne sert à rien de soulever cette
question il est impossible de contenir
l'élévation de la température à 1 degrés
d'ici l'année 2100 par exemple c'est
impossible
les signataires de l'accord de paris ce
sont seulement engagé à prendre toutes
les mesures possibles pour limiter
l'élévation de la température moyenne à
2 degrés maximum ou même à 1,5 degrés
d'ici la fin du 21e siècle
[Musique]
si l'humanité continue à évoluer en suit
sans prendre de mesures pour réduire les
émissions pour réduire son impact sur le
climat d'ici 2100 la température
augmentera de 4 à 5 2 me
les engagements de réduction des
émissions pris par certains pays exigent
des sommes importantes et cela ne
suffira toujours pas arrêter le
réchauffement ni de 2 degrés ni de 1,5
degré
c'est pourquoi les écoliers européens
sont en grève ils veulent faire
réfléchir à leurs contemporains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand j'étais enfant
personne ne parlait du réchauffement
climatique nous brûlions du charbon et
tout le monde était content we know
aujourd'hui nous sommes mieux informés
sur la question et je pense que la
science et l'éducation joue un rôle
crucial
je crois que nous sommes sur la bonne
voie et l'archipel du svalbard
le territoire norvégien le plus
septentrional languir vienne est l'une
des colonies les plus septentrionale au
monde mais les endroits qui sont censés
être les plus froids détiennent le
record du réchauffement climatique les
calotte glaciaire de l'arctique fondent
plus vite qu'elle ne gèle et deviennent
de plus en plus petit chaque année en
conséquence ces régions se réchauffe
plus rapidement que les autres
la température moyenne au svalbard est
de 4 degrés de plus qu'au début des
années 70 à la fin de ce siècle
elle pourrait encore augmenter de 10
degrés lorsque le permafrost fond le sol
devient plus mais nous avons déjà
enregistré des changements assez
important ici à longueur by npk les gens
sont obligés d'abandonner leurs maisons
en raison du risque d avalanche et à
cause du mouvement des sols certaines
maisons reposent sur des poteaux en bois
qui ne sont plus dans un sol sec ou
gelée et commence à pourrir les
changements sont donc littéralement
devant chez nous
la réserve mondiale de semences du
svalbard ou comme on l'appelle aussi le
bunker de l'apocalypse a été ouvert en
il semblait que le permafrost et la
faible activité sismique pourrait
garantir une conservation est aisé 2
millions de graines de partout dans le
monde
dans ce réfrigérateur souterrain mais ne
vend plus tard l'entrée a été inondée
les autorités affirment que les graines
n'ont pas été endommagés mais des
millions ont été dépensés en travaux de
réparation ces problèmes pourtant si
dissemblables en norvège et au yémen ont
été causés par les mêmes changements
climatiques la nécessité d'élaborer une
approche commune pour les résoudre
n'arrive pas à rassembler l'humanité
dont certaines parties du monde
les gens ont du mal à obtenir de la
nourriture il est probable que dans six
régions
la consommation d'énergie deviennent
plus importantes match de challenge cmda
la plupart des changements que l'on
perçoit d'aujourd'hui dans l'atmosphère
ont été causés par les émissions
produites par certains pays riches il ya
des des seniors nous avons d histoire et
d avenir différente miniac un avenir
commun à la planète et nous partageons
cette dernière chaque pays doit faire sa
part au mieux de ses capacités
de vastes territoires des régions du
grand nord en russie aux etats-unis et
au canada feront face au même sort
les infrastructures des zones où
existent le permafrost devront être
modifiés et adaptés au nouveau climat
moins de neige des pluies plus
abondantes
[Musique]
certains pays d'afrique et du
moyen-orient ressembleront au yémen
aujourd'hui on pourrait s'attendre à ce
que le changement climatique provoque
encore plus de mouvements migratoires
notamment à l'intérieur des pays et
comme nous le savons de notre étude
cela pourrait entraîner des conflits
armés dans certaines régions crans
reflète un groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat a reçu le prix nobel de la paix
en 2007 pour avoir dégagé un large
consensus sur le lien entre activité
humaine et réchauffement leur rapport
publié en 2010 8 décrit les moyens
d'influencer le climat de la planète
réduire les émissions nocives planter
des forêts promouvoir la culture
d'algues dans l'océan
une solution plus extrêmes y est même
mentionné la construction d'un bouclier
global le recours aux méthodes de
gestion des radiations solaires est
possible la plus connue consiste à
injecter des substances contenant du
soufre dans la stratosphère qui le
transforme ensuite en aérosol sulfurique
capable de réfléchir le rayonnement
solaire
c'est l'équivalent d'un phénomène
naturel qui se produit après de
puissants tirs option l'exemple le plus
récent et l'éruption du pinatubo
on attend quoi
[Musique]
après l'éruption du pinatubo en 1991 aux
philippines
un énorme nuage de poussière et de
cendres s'est formé que la lumière du
soleil ne pouvait pénétrer les émissions
atmosphériques du pinatubo a été la plus
importante du 20e siècle
l'éruption a conduit à une baisse de la
température moyenne sur la terre de 0.5
degrés aujourd'hui les scientifiques
envisagent de créer un tel bouclier mais
il ya encore un long chemin à parcourir
avant que cette idée puisse être mise en
oeuvre
je pense qu'étant donné la situation
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons plutôt
que de penser à contrôler les émissions
le moment est venu de réfléchir à la
façon d'en gérer les conséquences
comment nous sauver
prendre conscience de ce que nous avons
fait réduire notre impact sur la planète
et s'adapter au nouveau climat de l'air
anthropocène voici l'avenir complexe
difficile inévitable de l'humanité sur
terre